- You always have to fight for things
that are worth it.
So boring.
Everyone's doing the same thing.
Are you walking the dog,
or is the dog walking you?
The more brilliant people
that you hang around
the more inspired you get.
We're living in an age, in a society now,
where that is almost
looked at as a weakness.
You turn the apple cart
over and then what?
Then everyone's looking at an apple cart
that's turned over and they're like,
well now what do I do?
In my mind, there's a little movie playing
and I always envision
scenarios and characters.
You could never compare, you know,
Picasso with Leger
I always tell people,
vacations are for people
who don't like their job.
I want to conquer the world.
- She's an American singer, songwriter,
actress, and business woman.
- She pushed the boundaries
in her music and videos.
- She sold over 300 million records
and she is the world's best selling
female recording artist of all time.
- She's Madonna,
and here are her top 10 rules for success.
(rocket exploding)
- I think the best
advice I can give anyone
male or female, is that, you know,
you have to really believe
in what you're doing.
I think having a good job
and having work is,
it's hard to come by
and being able to do what you
want to do with your life.
You have to be willing, first of all,
you have to be really passionate
about what you do and really
believe in what you do,
'cause there's going to be a lot of fights
and battles and struggles along the way,
so my best advice is to
really believe and love what you do.
(audience applauding)
Because a the end of the day,
nothing, you know,
you always have to fight for things
that are worth it.
Put your boxing gloves on.
- [Interviewer] Will we
ever see choreography
in a video again, meter, dancing?
- It's possible.
It's just that I got so sick
of all the videos everybody's making
where there's like, the troupe of dancers
and the singer standing in front of it
and everybody was moving in unison,
I thought, so boring.
Everyone's doing the same thing.
I wanted to get away from all of that
but, yeah, I could see
doing something like that.
Actually, because now, not
so many people are doing it,
so be something different.
- You will definitely always
go against the grain, won't you?
- Well, I will always take
the road less traveled by.
We're all controlled by our ego.
We're all slaves to our ego.
Everything we do is about our ego.
- Guilty as charged.
- Absolutely and so am I,
and so are we all.
If I didn't have a huge
ego, I wouldn't be here.
At a certain point,
you have to understand
that it is, you know,
it's your dog and it's like,
are you walking the dog
or is the dog walking you?
The best way to be inspired as an artist
is to be around humanity.
Whether you're walking down the street,
or you're standing in the
middle of a shopping mall,
or you're hanging around a lot
of really brilliant people.
I mean, you know, the smarter,
I mean, the more brilliant people
that you hang around,
the more inspired you get, you know.
I just like to be around talented people,
whether I use what I learned
from them in my work or not.
I always say to myself,
why aren't people inspired
by everything that I've accomplished?
Why is everybody afraid?
You know, I think my strength,
and that's like, the hardest thing
that I've had to sort of grasp and accept
is that my surviving, and my strength,
and the things that I've accomplished,
isn't inspirational to other people.
It's frightening, I think.
I think it's because
so many people are so afraid to,
to have a point of view,
to strike out on their own,
and to try and realize
one of their dreams.
To see someone else doing it,
we're living in an age, in a society now,
where that is almost
looked at as a weakness,
something to be ashamed of.
- [Interviewer] Most
people are immobilized
by the fear of failure.
- Yeah, absolutely.
When they see someone
else doing really well,
it's like, I think,
deep down inside, it's human nature,
to want to destroy them,
to try to destroy them,
to try to bring them down to your level
so you can feel good about yourself.
- You have done a really
good job, though, I think,
of making the rest of us
think you don't care very much
what other people think.
- I'm a good actress.
(Madonna laughing)
I mean, I'm a rebel,
and, you know, that's
the stance of a rebel.
The stance of a rebel is, you know,
I can't say bad words
on T.V. but, you know,
I don't care what you think.
If it's just for the sake
of upsetting the apple cart,
you're not really helping people.
You turn the apple cart
over and then what?
Then everyone's looking at an apple cart
that's turned over and they're like,
well, now what do I do?
- So, you've done a little of that,
- God, yeah.
- just for the sake of it.
- Just for the sake of it.
- When I write music,
I like to write them, like,
in my mind there's a little movie playing.
I always envision
scenarios and characters,
and of course,
it's not always something
that I've experienced,
but I always say it in the first person,
so it becomes,
it seems like it's a personal thing.
They're just usually ideas that amuse me.
I mean, sometimes they're things
that I think are erotic.
Sometimes they're things that I think
would be interesting
to write a song about,
because no one's ever
written a song about it.
You know, I mean,
I'm influenced by many things
and my inspirations come
from lots of different places
and sometimes I know
I'm purposely being funny
or ironic, you know.
Sometimes I just like the
way words sound, I mean.
I just think that people,
it's pointless for people to
get into a creative arena,
and say, I want to be the best.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you know,
there are, everyone has what they have.
They say what they say
and you could never compare, you know,
Picasso with Leger.
Everybody has something different to say.
It's silly to get in there and say,
my brush stroke is better
than another person's.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's better to say,
am I being true to myself
and is this what I want to say
and have I expressed myself, you know,
the way I want to express myself?
- Yeah.
- That's what it's all about.
- Would you, are you trying to,
would you like to find another Madonna?
- Well, I don't think that's possible.
(Madonna laughing)
What I'm trying to find is really,
I don't know,
fresh talent that's saying something,
cutting edge, new.
I mean we found some really good groups.
We've signed a couple groups so far
and I'm really excited about them.
- This obviously is going to mean
more work for you, presumably.
- It is already more work for me.
- I'm not saying it's perfect
but some people, perhaps,
would think if they had that much success,
if they had that much wealth,
maybe one thing they'd want to do,
is while they were still
young enough to enjoy it,
is maybe take a year off,
kick around the world, you know,
go fishing, whatever.
- I enjoy what I do.
I mean, life is short
and I have lots of things to do
and I see talent out there
and I want to do something with it.
I like watching, I like planting seeds
and watching it grow,
you know what I mean?
It's inspiring.
- Do you actually take a holiday off?
- Mm. What is that?
I always tell people,
vacations are for people
who don't like their job.
I like what I do.
- What I would like to ultimately achieve,
I already told Dick Clark once
on American Bandstand,
so I'll repeat it again,
and annoy everyone who was
annoyed before when I said it,
I want to conquer the world.
(Madonna laughing)
- Thank you so much for watching us.
We made this video because
Anna Young asked us to.
If there's someone else
that you'd like us to profile,
please leave it in the comments
and we'll see what we can do.
- We'd also love to know
which one of Madonna's top 10 rules
meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments below
and we'll join the discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe
and we'll see you soon.
(rocket exploding)
- My Kabbala teacher, one
of them, used to say to me,
when in doubt, act like God.
Then you think, well what does that mean?
It's like, describe God.
God would be compassionate, unconditional,
all-giving, all-loving,
so, when in doubt,
behave that way.
You'll never go wrong.
- [Interviewer] Do you
like being powerful,
do you like power?
- Who doesn't?
- Not everybody.
Do you like--
- Name one person
who doesn't like power.
- Everybody wants to be famous.
- No it's not just fame.
Power is, anyone can have power.
It's how you feel about yourself.
It's how you carry yourself.
It's the effect that you have on people.
It doesn't necessarily,
it's not synonymous with fame.
I think that,
I don't think you would find a human being
on this Earth that wasn't
interested in power.
I think that two years ago,
I wasn't really sure why,
what I was on this Earth for.
I think I was mostly concerned with
getting things for myself.
- [Interviewer] Mm hmm.
- You know, more clothes,
more money, more popularity,
more approval, more
boyfriends, more every.
It's just like, I wasn't really thinking,
I was just doing,
- Mm hmm. So not living
consciously really?
- Yeah.
- I think I probably had
some conscious moments.
- Right.
- I don't think I was,
like, brain dead, but,
(audience laughing)
but--
- But you know what I mean
not living consciously,
like a lot of people are just kind of
going through the motions
no matter what the motions are.
- You can't do that.
- Yeah.
- No, I think I just
kind of woke up and said,
okay, what am I on this Earth for?
Why are we all on this Earth for?
We're here to love.
We're here to share.
That's it.
So, that's--
- The difference.
- Totally.